okay so hey good morning everyone my
name is God and first of all I want to
thank the organizers it's just been a
day but it's been super interesting
today I want to tell you about this work
preference inform friends this is a
recent collaboration with both Michael
and Alexandra which are here and guy
Roth bloom from Weitzman good so the
outline to the stack is hopefully
Alexandra stock from yesterday has
gotten you kind of sufficiently worried
about issues of discrimination and
targeted advertising so I want to kind
of follow up on that and kind of start
by discussing what individual fairness
looks like in this setting and basically
my main point is going to be that it is
somehow kind of insufficient and I'll
present our suggestion which we call
preference informed individual fairness
and extension of individual fairness for
this study and I'll discuss some of its
properties so kind of the connection to
kind of more preference based
definitions from the NV freeness from
the fair division literature and kind of
how do you do a fishing optimization and
I want a Charlie kind of a couple of
words for the discussion at the end I
think it touches on kind of some
interesting questions that we mentioned
today and yesterday okay good so I'll
start with kind of a warm up example for
for what individual fairness is so this
is kind of a very toy example in which
suppose we have this binary
classification task where an individual
is mapped onto this binary outcome so
say loan approved or loan denied and
suppose that kind of individuals come in
one of two types so either their
creditworthy which I'll denote with
green or they're not credit worthy which
I'll denote with red and now let's take
a look at kind of two scenarios so the
first scenario we have a credit worthy
individual this is the first individual
and they're approved the loan and the
second thing and the second person is
not a credit worthy individual and
they're denied the loans okay so we have
two individuals winner which are getting
different outcomes right but we don't
think of
kind of discrimination right the first
person you know they may be bummed out
because they're not getting the loan but
it's not unfair okay
the second scenario on the other hand we
have two individuals which are both
credit worthy yet one is approved alone
and the other is denied little okay so
that's kind of they're similar with
respect to the task at hand yet they're
getting different treatments so that
seems kind of problematic okay so that's
exactly the types of evils that
individual fairness sets out to prove it
so formally we're going to be talking
about probabilistic classifiers
right so these are mappings from the
input space to a distribution over the
outcome space and we're going to say
that such a classifier is individually
fair it's basically for any two
individuals this constraint hold which
what does it mean is that if two
individuals are similar with respect to
this task specific metric lowercase D
then their outcome distributions should
be similar okay so essentially in this
example the metric was you know are they
both credit worthy or not and the
constraint was that if they're both
credit worthy then they should be
getting kind of both accepted or granted
alone or not good so how does this look
like in in the context of targeted
advertising so now we don't have just
this binary outcome but we have kind of
multiple outcomes which is you know
which ad is this person going to be
shown and if you think about it it's not
that clear what a single task specific
metric here would even look like right
so kind of this was addressed by this ad
working a 1/2 paper earlier this year we
called this setting the multiple task
set it and basically what they assume is
kind of each of the outcomes they think
of it as a separate task and then make
sense to think of a separate metric for
each one of the outcomes so kind of
think of the first ad you know being an
ad for shampoo we have a metric for
which two individuals are similar with
respect to this ad and so on so what
does individual Ferris look like in this
context so this is are they defined it
to be multiple tasks individual Fitness
basically the same constraint form
before just simultaneously for
each one of the outcomes okay so kind of
think you know if two individuals are
similar with respect to one of the ads
then they should be seeing that ad with
similar probabilities okay so that makes
sense and there are a couple of
challenges in how you would actually
implement this thing so I don't want to
talk about it too much but kind of the
main challenge is obviously you know
where do you get how do you get your
hands on these metrics and the second
this is covered in that work of rental
paper is the fact that kind of naive
composition fails okay so I don't want
to spend too long on it but basically
it's not enough for each of the
advertisers separately to kind of behave
in a way that that is individually fair
with respect to their ad this won't
necessarily compose into a fair solution
so these are good and important
challenges but kind of the perspective I
want to take for this talk is kind of
taking a step back and actually asking
you know putting aside these issues is
this actually the solution concept that
we're after
for this problem kind of the you know
spoiler the answer is going to be that
not quite so to see why the answer is
not quite let's kind of revisit this the
warm-up example that we had before so
remember we had two individuals both
creditworthy so similar with respect to
this task and they were getting
different treatment this was a violation
of individual fairness and that was kind
of in accordance with our you know
intuition for that this is unfair so how
does this example kind of translate to
this new setting so now suppose you know
we have a couple of ads the first is the
shampoo ad and the final is the loaner
so suppose we have again these two
individuals they are similar with
respect to the loan ad the first person
is seeing they don't add and the second
person is seeing a different ad say
shampoo ad okay so for exactly the same
reason as before this is a violation of
the notion of multiple tasks individual
fairness right but if you actually look
at it you know kind of this seemed a lot
the first example seemed a lot like
discrimination this doesn't seem kind of
necessarily bad or evil right
so if you think about it a little bit
what's the difference between these two
examples so I want to argue that the
difference is in the individuals
preferences over the outcome space okay
so to see this point kind of in the
binary loan example presumably everyone
who's applied to get their own once the
loan right that's the good outcome
so denying a person of this good outcome
is not fair okay on the other hand here
we don't necessarily know anything about
kind of the ads that people want to see
and in particular it makes perfect sense
for two individuals to be credit worthy
but for one of them to kind of not be
interested in the loan ad or just prefer
another ad is this clear
good so basically I've made the point
that kind of individual fairness as is
can sometimes be too restrictive okay
actually the easiest kind of examples to
see this is the fact that the allocation
in which every person actually gets
their favorite outcome is not
necessarily individually fair okay
before I'm gonna kind of get to our
proposal I do want to mention kind of a
naive solution so one thing you know
looking back at at this example you
might say well you know the first person
and the second person yes they're
similar with respect to the stone ad but
the fact that they have different
preferences maybe should render them as
not similar okay so what this kind of
suggests is that maybe you could
actually incorporate the preferences
directly into the metric and then stay
with the same definition individual
fairness that we had before so formally
this would look like you know you could
define kind of a metric that says that
two individuals are similar only if
they're similar with respect to the
metric and also with respect to their
preferences for these so I don't have a
lot of time kind of this is it's a good
approach but it can also be used to kind
of discriminate so it's not we don't
want to use this definition so putting
all these observations together a kind
of main point is that this does call for
a further study of what fairness means
in the presence of these possibly
diverse preferences over the outcome
space good so this won't be too
technical but I do want to kind of
remind the setup so we're thinking about
allocations which are mappings from the
space of individuals to distribution
over the outcome space so I'll use PI of
I to kind of denote the outcome
distribution over as that person I
receives and since we're going to be
talking about preferences I need to say
something about how we're going to model
these preferences so most generally what
I want to think about is just every
individuals every individual having this
reflexive and binary relation over the
outcomes-based the possible
distributions that they can get so if I
prefers an outcome P over an outcome Q
I'll use this notation okay kind of this
doesn't assume a lot we'll see later
that in order to kind of have efficient
algorithms we'll need to assume
something more about these preferences
okay good so kind of to illustrate this
point graphically so we have this set of
all the possible allocations and within
it there's this kind of smaller subset
of other individually fair allocations
and I've argued that this doesn't kind
of sufficiently capture all the
allocations that we think of as being
kosher okay in particular there's this
very nice allocation in which everyone
receives their favorite outcome which is
outside okay so what we kind of want to
nail down is you know this set of really
all the allocations that we think of as
fair and kind of the challenge is that
you know we're going to have we'll have
kind of different types of deviations
from individual fairness and how do we
say which deviations are okay and which
deviations count as discrimination so
that's what I want to try and formalize
good so the guiding principle to kind of
formalize this is to say that
allocations that deviate from individual
fairness will be considered okay as long
as these deviations are in line with the
individuals preferences okay so let's
revisit kind of the example that we had
before so intuitively I want to build up
to the idea that if the second person
prefers the shampoo ad then I want to
say that this outcome is fair okay I
want a definition that that supports
this so the idea is going to be let's
look at the second person with respect
to the first person right so if I would
have insisted on individual fairness in
this context the second person has to
see the loan ad right because they're
similar to another person who's staying
the loan ad so what I want to argue is
that this allocation is okay because I'm
giving the second person something that
they prefer over the individual fair
allocation
okay so I think the intuition is really
simple kind of I'll give the actual
definition which is a bit cumbersome but
I think it's natural so we're going to
say that an allocation satisfies this
notion of multiple task preference
inform fairness basically for every
individual I earn for every other
individual J there exists this other
allocation which other know with PI
superscript j of I okay think of this as
the fictitious allocation that I'm
comparing to so this should satisfy two
things so first of all this allocation
should be individually fare with respect
to J's allocation so this is just the
same constraint that I had before and
the second is that I needs to prefer
their current allocation this is PI of I
over this fictitious allocation okay so
this again just to formalize the
intuition that kind of for every person
with respect to every other person I'm
if I'm deviating from the individually
fair allocation it's only to give them
something that they prefer in for each
of us to pick a different AF reference
point we all have to the current
allocation over particular - reference
point exactly
some yes there exist some fictitious
allocation which is both individually
fair and that I prefer my current
outcome - okay can you I we can do a
bunch of other things with quantifiers
here yeah the other one I think we can
talk about it like I don't have a kind
of a very good answer I think this is
something that we're we're kind of happy
with it's sufficiently expressive and
also gives the similar types of
protections that individual fairness
kind of in spirit gives guarantee you
groups green-blue people this stopped me
from giving the great people always
their most preferred outcome as long as
the blue people don't like that outcome
okay so I don't I don't ever give the
boot people what they want
people don't like with the great people
I always give with great people with it
so we need to assume something about
who's similar to who so in this example
I don't you didn't specify that there's
a separate question of kind of you know
the fairness of the outcome space itself
which could also kind of be relevant
here so I'll talk about it in the end
but kind of you know with the if upfront
all the outcomes are the outcomes that
one half of the population likes best
then this doesn't kind of address this
okay and make but maybe like if that's
right like that's true then maybe
they're not actually so Simone
individual fairness we would say that
the allocation where all everybody got
the green people's favorite audition is
perfectly fair because everyone is being
treated similarly so so this is only
it's less restricted but if I understood
correctly ellonija is asking other
yeah like am I allowed to DV in from the
individually fair allocation only when
it prefers the green people essentially
can I be unfair in that way so I think
that in the example that you gave you
know the answer is no because the ones
that are if I'm deviating from you know
giving the good outcome to everyone and
now for half of the population I'm
giving a different outcome then I'm only
allowed to do this if this half of the
outcome if there are no preferences so
the solution starts at the end when all
the chores architectures have been
determined and in a way also feeds back
into them because they're reinforced but
maybe that's not so I'll say something
about this at the end so okay good so I
do want to kind of discuss the
relationship between this definition
that I just gave and kind of you know
this other literature on unfair division
which has a lot of fairness definitions
that are kind of inherently preference
based so I'll focus on envy freenas kind
of this is the most class closely
related one which basically says that
kind of you know in the context of
dividing this cake to individuals that
no individual prefers in other
individuals outcome okay so kind of
everyone likes their part of the cake
the best and formally in the annotation
that we have set up this means that for
every individual I and for every other
individual J individual I prefers there
location pi PI over pi of J okay so kind
of get graphically going back to this
illustration right now this the set of
envy free allocations kind of by
definition includes this allocation in
which everyone receives their favorite
outcome I want to argue however that
it's also too restrictive okay and kind
of the easiest way to see this is in the
case that everyone has identical
preferences over the outcome space so
think kind of the binary lone example
what entry freeness essentially says is
you know everyone should receive the
loan with the same rate okay so that's
kind of not the direction that we want
to go to and essentially the the problem
is that envy freeness you know coming
from this literature on fair division
kind of assumes that everyone is equally
deserving okay but really that's not the
context that we think of fairness in the
context of machine learning which is you
know there are like these bummers so
this is the first example that I had
with you know the second person not
receiving there no but that wasn't
unfair that was a bummer for them so I
want to differentiate between bummers
and discrimination and envy freeness on
itself doesn't really do this okay I'm
kind of one nice perspective is to
actually look at this definition as kind
of being in between both of these
notions of individual fairness and and
beefiness
kind of capturing somehow the best of
both of these works so formally we can
actually show that preference in full
face is a relaxation of both these
definitions so it's a very kind of
one-line argument so I want to give it
so basically I want to show that if I
start with both in individually fair
allocation and an envy free allocation
and this allocation satisfies preference
in form frames so I have to show these
two these two things so let me start
with individual fairness so in this case
I'm going to take the fictitious
allocation PI J over to just be eyes
current allocation okay so now if I look
at the first constraint that's just the
definition of individual fairness so
that holds and the second constraint now
is I prefers PI of I over PI of I and
since this is weak preferences that just
holds okay now for for
Venis let's do exactly the same but this
time taking the fictitious allocation to
be Jai's allocation please so now the
first constraint is the one that holds
kind of trivially right the distance you
know assuming this is kind of a metric
than the distance between PI of J and PI
of J is 0 and the lowercase D is between
0 and 1 and the second constraint which
is that I prefers PI of I over PI of J
that's exactly the definition of n be
friends ok so that's kind of a very
simple argument and I won't mention it
but you can actually show that you know
this notion of preference in form first
is equivalent to kind of a variant of
envy fairness which we call metric and
refresh and basically the idea of metric
and Rufus is kind of the same and V
freeness constrained for every eye on
every J but up to this factor of the
distance between I and J okay so the way
to think about this is that if the
metric specifies that two individuals
are different then that would
essentially kind of lift the envy
freeness constraint off of that pair
okay so that's I think kind of bridges
you know between this very nice notion
and the context that we're thinking
about good so I want to quickly say
something about optimizations all right
kind of going back to the targeted
advertising world you know we might
think of you know Facebook is kind of
optimizing their own objective but we
want to introduce this constraint so
we're interested in problems of the you
know of the form kind of minimizing some
convex objective subject to the
allocation satisfying preference in form
fairness and yeah this is when the
preferences are known and I'll get back
to it so I want to show that kind of
this can be done efficiently and the
important thing to note here is that if
I want to talk about efficient
algorithms I have to you know start
assuming something more about the
preferences because otherwise you know
this kind of outcome space Delta of C
it's like it's exponential on its own so
I won't be able to have kind of
efficient algorithms so in the people we
kind of treat this slightly more
generally for this talk I just want to
talk about you know kind of
standard assumption for the preferences
to follow expected utility theory so
basically what this says is that I'm
gonna assume that every individual has
kind of a utility per outcome through
deterministic outcome so that means that
I can attach a numerical quantity to you
know how much I like the first add the
second add and so forth and then the
utility from a distribution over as is
just the expectation so in this notation
outcome is C like seeing in C that's
just an ad so that's saying yes no yeah
just for ya like do you want the shampoo
add okay so what I want to show is that
when F is convex then I can formulate
the optimization problem that I had
before it's kind of a convex program and
solve it efficiently so the argument is
very simple I want to kind of sketch it
out so what I'm gonna do is kind of the
straightforward thing would be to have
you know variable in the program for you
know every person's outcome so I'm going
to have that this is a vector of PI of I
but I'm also going to have another
vector for the fictitious allocation of
I with compared to person J okay so kind
of this introduces an order of x-squared
more variables and now I'll kind of go
quickly but because I want to get to the
discussion but basically I want to argue
that the preference in form fairness our
constraints are linear in all of these
variables so I have to say you know that
each one is legal kind of legal outcome
distribution that's simple I need to say
that this PI J of I is individually fair
by definition you know that would also
be a linear constraint and finally I
want to say that I weakly prefers PI of
I over PI J of iron from the assumption
on the linearity of the preferences
that's also linear okay so that's kind
of a sanity check that we're not making
this optimization problem
significantly harder than it was with
individual things we have a couple of
more things in the paper which I'll kind
of briefly mentioned so I did to file
this for the multiple tasks setting
everything I said is also for the single
kind of standard setting you can also
similarly use this idea to extend other
notions of fairness so we focused on
individual fairness but you can
similarly do it for like group fairness
notions and we have some discussion
which is important on you know what
happens to Social Welfare under
preference in forum fairness but the
idea is that kind of we don't
necessarily guarantee that the Social
Welfare will go up but that's in line
with our objective of kind of prevention
preventing discrimination from the
objective of making everyone happy okay
so this is the final discussion side so
I do want to mention you know that there
are like sources of discrimination that
this model you know toy model doesn't
address which is first of all the prep
the fact that we're assuming the
preferences are known and you know how
do you actually estimate this in
practice
how are you not introduced bias there
and the second is that the outcome space
is considered fixed so again what I said
before to Aloni if every like if the
outcomes are off the bat bad for some
parts of the population then we don't we
don't escape this there's this you know
question of like ah another fairness
definition you know do we really need
this and I want to argue that the answer
is yes and really if you think about it
you know if we want to start
incorporating these fairness constraints
and this is kind of similar to Jamie's
point from before
in systems that are more complex and
more real-world like than we have to
like we should be revisiting the
definitions that kind of worked in these
toy models and making sure that they're
still doing what we want them to do and
I think in this work we kind of put the
emphasis on you know this aspect of
preferences which if you don't
incorporate it into the definitions that
you're doing you might be doing
something which could be bad and you
know there could be other interesting
aspects
so I think that's a nice Avenue for
future work and I want to end with kind
of you know also a conceptual argument
for why incorporating the individual's
preferences into the definition is
important and this is you know feel free
to push back but I think that kind of at
the end of the day there's always going
to be the gap between you know the
parties that are specifying the fairness
constraints and those individuals that
are eventually going to be affected by
them and I think that the definitions
should kind of leave some leeway for you
know individuals that maybe don't want
or are not interested in whatever the
fair solution that you know the platform
thought is appropriate so I think that's
kind of a nice motivation for this
definition begin the humanists I think
that to the extent that the assumption
is that processes are fix we disconnect
from a variable so that should be said
up front the second thing about
preferences is to be clear about
personal preferences - could be
consumers preference to begin with right
so some people may say well my
preferences is not seasoned
that's my preference take it into
account adjust any constraint on the
type of processes so usually Netflix you
say we include the incorporate some horn
honks related preferences will be going
in town
which is not all purposes are treated
equally for there to be moral
justification for accounting purposes so
these are just a broad situation however
I do think that you're right in the
sense that pretentious memories the
question then that matter then the
question becomes the context and what
bothered me from the start was your
treatment of loans and ads alike so
heads again drawing back on yesterday's
discussion ads our manipulative
persuasion to make us interested in
something loans is something that we
decide we need it's certainly good that
the question is whether we have a right
to or not but this is no this is not a
certain this is not similar conceptually
similar I agree I think it was mostly
kind of to motivate the definition so
then the question becomes in which
cluster for think choices with respect
the whiskers of courses we should take
which type of preferences in half
okay there's a newbie I'm not trying to
be follow the definition so let me ask
the following scenario suppose there is
a perfect one outcomes that nobody wants
but really annoying if I use the point
of comparison this allocation of
comparison and everyone will get to see
that horrible ads that no one wants does
that make all other allocations so the
starting the starting point with
individual fairness is that it doesn't
rule out this allocation in which
everyone gets the bad outcome you know
kind of as long as you know right so so
now if I want to look at you know
starting from this allocation
I don't know now let's give let's choose
one person and give them a good outcome
so that doesn't satisfy this definition
because suppose that there are is like
one other person who is similar to this
person that got a good outcome now
they're looking at this person and
they're saying I don't prefer my current
outcome over the allocation that would
have satisfied individual fairness but
does that make sense
[Music]
so